>>> SO, AFTER 36 HOURS, SAID YOU
FOUND THE KILLER.
WE CAN GO.
>> UNRELATED HAS ANYONE HEARD
THE NEW BILL CATCH ON?
>> HE'S SUCH A FORWARD THINKING
ARTIST.
>> FACETIME.
>> SPEAKING OF STRAIGHT FIRE,
KNOW WHAT I'VE BEEN INTO LATELY?
THE MAEFRP AING BAND VERSION OF
DON'T STOP BELIEVING.
>> WHAT?
>> I'VE BEEN MAINLINING THE
TRACK.
I HAVE IT CUED UP.
YOU WANT TO HEAR IT?
>> NO, THAT'S OKAY.
>> LET ME BREAK YOU OFF A PIECE.
>> DON'T EVER CALL PLAYING MUSIC
THAT.
>> CORTANA PLAY DON'T STOP 11 BY
OHIO STATE MARCHING BAND.
>> THERE'S A TYPO IN SPOTIFY.
SHUT UP.
>> YOU GUYS HEAR IT?
>> HEAR WHAT?
>> IT'S TUBAS PLAYING --
[ LAUGHTER]
>> WHO THINKS OF THAT?
>> MARCHING BANDS.
>> WHAT ARE WE WAITING FOR?
>> STEAM RISING AFTER
PERCOLATING UP AND UPWARD,
FASTER, WALKING DOWN THE STREET.
FEELING INVINCIBLE, LIKE YOUR
WHOLE LIFE IS AHEAD OF YOU,
YOU'RE ON YOUR WAY TO THE HIGH
SCHOOL GRADUATION AND YOU
BUILDING UNTIL SUDDENLY --
>> IS IT OVER?
>> IT'S JUST BEGINNING.
>> HEY -- ♪
>> LIKE ANYTHING IS POSSIBLE ALL
AT ONCE AGAIN.
>> WAIT.
THE INSTRUMENTS ARE DOING THE
THING THAT STEPHEN TYLER IS
SINGING.
>> STEPHEN TYLER WASN'T IN
JOURNEY.
>> IT DOESN'T MATTER, OKAY.
THE MUSIC IS -- AM I IN HEAVEN
OR ON RAINBOW ROAD IN MARIO KART
8?
>> IT'S THE SONG.
>> AND NOW THERE GOES.
THE TRUMPETS.
>> I DID NOT KNOW THEY COULD DO
GUITAR.
>> THEY CAN.
♪ LIVING DOWN IN SAN FRAN SIS
>> THOSE ARE NOT THE WORDS.
>> AND NO ONE HAS EVER CALLED IT
SAN FUR SIS.
>> NO ONE IS GETTING MY MONEY
EXCEPT CLARA.
>> THIS IS THE FIRST TIME
MEETING YOU EXCEPT FOR YOUR
SOCIAL MEDIA POST.
>> THEY'RE LIKE THE BIGGEST BAND
IN THE WORLD AND VIOLINS.
MY GOD.
IT'S THE SAME THING.
YES.
♪ OH ♪
>> SERIOUSLY, IMAGINE PLAYING
MARIO KART 8 AND HEARING THIS?
>> THAT INSPIRED ME TO DO SO
MUCH BETTER AT MARIO KURKS ART.
AND WHILE I'M CRUISING DOWN
RAINBOW ROAD.
>> MARCHING BAND VERSION OF
DON'T STOP BELIEVING TAKES PLACE
ON RAINBOW ROAD?
>> IT DOES.
IF YOU DON'T STOP 11.
AND THEY'RE TAKING IT HOME.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> THAT WAS AMAZING.
I'D NEVER HEARD A SONG WITHOUT
WORDS BEFORE.
I CAN'T BELIEVE IT'S OVER.
>> IT'S JUST BEGINNING.
LIFE THAT IS.
>> ARE YOU GUYS ABOUT TO HOOK
UP?
>> IT MAKES SENSE.
>> YOU'RE BOTH GAY.
>> NOT ANYMORE.
>> I STILL AM.
>> KNEE.
ME TOO.
>> OH.
♪